Oudi
know that already
if I'm not involved in no one I will
help you with money but you expect me to
fight on your behalf and I know you are
looking for any time to bring me down
I'm going to do that and the reality
even my daughter
years old she told me in school said I
said she
don't like Saudi 12 years old like Saud
look how brain washed you know you know
I have seen a country that's
Saudes that me peran
America
in America while my country is yes
become warrior Muslims
Allah
kafir and brit
amer
country in
and amer
under
the
other countries to get their
companions Quraysh
Quraysh
[Music]
Muhammad, may God bless him and grant him peace
Ok so what was the ball of so did when
he had a treat peacey of
then he took revenge for his companions
because now he's going to go to war with
and
his allies they have they not to get
involved because they have treat
but he never got even though med has arm
he
one of
Saladin  Al-Ayoubi
Saad Al-Ayoubi Al-
Aqsa
Normalization
H explain
re if you  peace and everything you
back to the leaders
you have been expired in the Ran Allah said
And if they listen
to God to the Messenger and the command is from them
If aff security comes to them to
have to the
leaders and sch the leaders areing
the tell me this ver is the Ran every place every
time if it is so how we
apply this verse
because believeire
May there leaders anyore so this verse
over 100 years expired to them we can
apply it anymore
you see how so
now if I return to the leader and scholar
I will be Allah  will reward me for the
Quran
now if the leaders
understand if they will be responsible Praise be to
God
war
politics
people
about
these are things
about and before speak about unity
Bin Salman
so-and-so Glory be to
God
God does not change a people until he changes what is in a people
You know like a lot of people say
how many Muslims are in the
Moroc Algeria to
come to Europe are they coming to Europe to
Europe for dunia so it's okay for you to
seek is haram
like people say in Saudi I see people in
Saudi from other country smoking
cigarettes
smoking cigarettes that shows you what
regard what you are going
people
H
unless if unless God willing  A hypocrite, a hypocrite,
Praise be to God, Glory be to God,
Ali bin Abi Talib,
your father Omar people, it is time
Don't tell me
and Europe
and then if someone else you
Pakistan hason turya, Al-Sanaifan, praise You imagine
I punch you and you bring your older brother and your older brother
keeps saying
you punch him again I will do something
to you and I punish you again and he
keep saying it say you know what I'm
going to punish you for what you do now
so I'm attacking  you now
I keep talking they said we going to
attack you directly
this the top general of Iran Iran did spoken
you know the truth has to be you
imagine
the top of
the army
and look
nuclear
spots
like one guy said
houses
house Iran
how
they attack it easily
fight
doesn't make any sense
just say you fighting for your own
country you have the right now does Iran
have a right to fight for his political
existence they have a right
this is something which you have to say
they have a right but don't against us
say you're fighting for  You,
the Shiites,
see the
issue of Palestine as an issue. Glory be to Him
God is the context, Glory be to
God, my
brother, and we seek refuge in God from the hypocrites of belief
and soul.
This is
finally, by
God,
Iraq, the
Shiites, Iraq. May
God protect you, my brother, may God guide you, may God bring
healing.
[Laughter] It's
known, known,
the cloud and the monkeys and the
donkeys to be Sunni and they are free, but
you can deceive them, they cannot deceive us, that's why they hate
us too much. Selfies are very smart,
they are
the